man kann nicht mehr an sich halten die
usa seien an dem konflikt in der ukraine
schuld russland wäre sich nur sagt der
mann den millionen in china zu hören er
argumentiert mit händen füßen oder damit
schäfer sie haben russland immer weiter
drangsaliert bis es das nicht mehr
ausgehalten dann eines tages schenkt
russland zurück und deutschland fragt
warum schlägst du jemanden
ein assistent und mehrere kameras seine
botschaften sollen professionell
rüberkommen denn zimmermann ist ein
wichtiger mann in china einer der
berühmten staatstreuen influenza der in
den sozialen medien propaganda
verbreitet 30 millionen hängen an seinen
lippen
ich will die deutschen politiker
kritisiert sie liefern waffen damit
hilft deutschland der einfache nicht
sondern es gefährdet den frieden und
gießt weiter öl ins feuer
die achse moskau peking stellt sich
gegen die alte westlich geprägte
weltordnung seit skis machtantritt haben
sich beide präsidenten
38 mal persönlich oder virtuell
getroffen sie eint das weltbild dass
länder wie die ukraine nur marionetten
der nato sind aber der internationale
druck auf peking wächst sich von
russland zu distanzieren der einsatz ist
hoch
[Musik]
die internationale gemeinschaft muss
aufpassen nicht in einen kalten krieg
rein zu rutschen und zwar nicht nur mit
russland sondern auch mit china die
auswirkungen auf die weltwirtschaft
während dramatisch die
wirtschaftsordnung der letzten 30 jahre
steht auf dem spiel
[Musik]
lienz job ist china der welt als
friedliches weltoffenes land zu
verkaufen
sie ist eine starjournalisten sie
arbeitet für den chinesischen
staatssender zitieren der auf englisch
sendet sie will ein china zeigen dass
die nähe zu putin auch diskutiert
es gibt auch eine neue chinesen die
nicht putin unterstützen das
meinungsbild ist eben nicht einseitig
absolut nicht
viele haben eindringliche debatten was
jetzt geschehen muss
im chinesischen internet äußert sich das
volksempfinden dass der staat zu lässt
dort fast ausschließlich solidarität für
putin er wird gefeiert als ein mann der
mit fast 70 jahren noch einmal sein
leben riskiert um sein land zu
verteidigen
besonders aktiv ja sie tun vater chinese
mutter russin sie spricht das aus was
viele chinesen denken und fühlen
[Musik]
manche länder mögen russland nicht aber
der westen traut sich nicht sich mit
russland anzulegen weil alle wissen
russland hat china als mächtigen großen
bruder lang lebe die russisch
chinesische freundschaft
die chinesischen hauptnachrichten
übernehmen bewusst die russische lesart
zum ukraine konflikt dort wird nicht von
einer invasion gesprochen dort wirkte
nicht kritisiert
stattdessen bekommen die chinesen
berichte des reporters nur yuan zu sehen
der für den chinesischen sender phoenix
die russische armee begleitet
wir sind an der frontlinie mario hinter
mir befindet sich die kampf zu dort
stoßen die russischen soldaten auf die
ukrainischen träumen
seine beiträge zeigen eine russische
armee die sich kümmert die zivilisten
rettet die chinesische bevölkerung soll
nichts von den grausamkeiten erfahren
wohin weiß dass china für den westen
neben russland auf der anklagebank sitzt
ihr job ist es chinas image davon zu
befreien
sie können doch nicht behaupten in china
hilft menschen umzubringen glauben sie
dass dann gibt es keine
gesprächsgrundlage
chinesen sind keine blutrünstigen
monster aber denken sie china kann
allein eine lösung finden
[Musik]
pekings führung steckt in einem dilemma
zwischen rußland treue und den versuchen
nicht den kontakt zur westlichen welt zu
verlieren denn sie braucht die
wirtschaftsbeziehung um weiter den
chinesischen aufstieg zu finanzieren
china ist keine militärische supermacht
sondern eine technologische und
wirtschaftliche es braucht den zugang zu
den westlichen es ist sehr wichtig für
das land dass es nicht wie russland ein
ausgestoßener der internationalen
gemeinschaft
china ein ausgestoßener fürs immer nur
eine westliche propaganda er will uns
unbedingt etwas zeigen fotos von seinem
letzten besuch in kiew das war vor 13
jahren er war auf einem kongress es ging
auch um völkerverständigung er weiß
nicht wie es heute seinen freunden geht
ich hoffe den jungen menschen geht das
gut ich hoffe es geht ihren familien gut
ich sende ihnen meine besten wünsche
sagen sie den deutschen zuschauern dass
der bürger sie man an gegen den krieg
er will frieden unterstützt aber
russland darin sieht er keinen
widerspruch denn der gegner heißt
amerika wie sagte maull alles was den
feind bekämpft müssen wir unterstützen
[Musik]